two thousand private households in
downtown Havana are to receive broadband
internet connections by year's end the
cables were laid by a Chinese
telecommunications company so far it's
been all but impossible to surf the net
privately in Cuba that has to change
well now wait a little it's a shame they
didn't do what they're doing now long
ago we were making a progress but it's
never too late things eventually come
around 2000 is an almost negligible
number everyone else has to use one of
the 150 state internet cafes and pay
about 4 euros an hour with the average
monthly wage at barely 20 euros that's a
luxury and many of the websites are
still censored last spring Google made
its grand entrance into Havana teaming
up with a local artist to open an
internet cafe patrons use one of 20
laptops to surf the net at high speed
free of charge
Oh Terry a guitar I wish we could have
this experience not just here but
throughout the country so not just two
or three people can enjoy it but someday
we can wake up and have it be completely
normal just to connect search and find
out about things like it is in other
countries como said till now internet
surfers in Havana have been limited to
the few public Wi-Fi hotspots that the
government set up in 2015 the nearly two
euro charge for an hour is still out of
reach for many Cubans and no private
connections were available dang ok don't
want a I have to go to a hotel or some
other place for this service and it's
expensive or I have to sit at a table on
the sidewalk with thousands of people
around that's less comfortable I think
it would be less complicated if I were
at home in a complete gauzy time we
gossip at least the pilot project will
crack the door to Cuba's digital future
and it will start in Havana's old town